[Musik]
wie kann man die macht eines landes
messen
ich meine damit dessen fähigkeit seinen
willen anderen ländern aufzuzwingen
wir könnten sein bruttoinlandsprodukt
sein wird das wachstum oder die größe
seiner armee messen
aber ich habe eine andere idee die
effektivste art der machtdemonstration
besteht wohl darin andere gleich große
länder zu einem großen zugeständnisse
oder opfer zu zwingen zu etwas das ihnen
gehörig gegen den strich geht aber dass
sie tun werden nur weil du diese ist nun
genau das versucht donald trump mit der
europäischen union
und was ist das für ein großes opfer das
die europäer dringen soll ganz einfach
habt eure verbindungen islamischen
republik
[Musik]
handelt es sich aber wirklich um ein so
großes opfer und vor allem deutschland
diese wette gewinnen nun genau diese
fragen werden wir im folgenden video
beantragt
[Applaus]
[Musik]
ein langes dass aldi in den enten filme
berühmt ist von denen wieder behauptet
die toll sie seien aber eigentlich hat
sie keine wirklich gesehen aber es gibt
etwas was du die iranischen wirtschaft
noch wesentlich wichtiger ist als
independent in wunsiedel autos
[Musik]
ja liebe zuschauer der iran ist einer
der größten automobilhersteller im
gesamten nahen osten ist der herren
das ist doch ein entwicklungs nachricht
war die sind doch so sehr sich das
überraschen mag die perser haben sogar
ihre eigene noten bierwagen zum beispiel
ist das auto das ihr hier sehen könnt
der chor ostermanns eine limousine die
in iran aserbaidschan und russland
verkauft wird außerdem durch in lila
okay man darf da kein hightech erwarten
die motoren sind als uns der hersteller
strotzt nur so vor extrem verbessert
[Musik]
was kann man auch 7000 dollar erwartet
ja das ist dass du dir vorstellen was
passieren würde wenn sie es mit moderner
technologie ein wenig mussten würden
eine ist so billige limousine würde es
vielen entwicklungsländern wie die
sprichwörtlichen warmen semmeln
und deswegen haben ab 2014 als die
meisten iranischen sanktionen aufgehoben
worden viele europäische unternehmen
ging diesem land zu investieren
nun gründet neu ist und welcher im iran
[Musik]
vor im iran wieder auf der spur vertrag
für fahrzeugfertigung abgeschlossen aber
hier gibt es weit mehr als die
marktkapitalisierung der iranischen
börse beträgt das dreifache ägyptischen
und die dort gelisteten unternehmen
decken ein sehr breites spektrum an
branchen ab im gegensatz zu anderen
ölreichen ländern der region weist die
iranische wirtschaft einen überraschend
hohen diversifikation osterath banken
gesellschaft und unserer hatte die
kommunikationsunternehmen andere
europäischen
vodafone steigt mit highway
partnerschaft in den iranischen markt
ein
und als ob das nicht genug wäre verfügt
der iran über eine recht gut
ausgebildete bevölkerung die
alphabetisierungsrate ist weitaus höher
als die in syrien im irak oder vielen
anderen nachbarländern mehr als vier
millionen würde haben an einer
universität studiert oder tun diese das
bedeutet es gibt viele gut ausgebildete
arbeitskräfte die für recht niedrige
löhne arbeiten
hinzu kommt dass die bevölkerung des
iran mit über 80 millionen menschen so
groß ist wie die deutschlands alles in
allem haben wir es also mit einem
hervorragenden zielland für
investitionen zu tun dennoch ebbt die
welle europäischen geldes lässt sich ab
[Musik]
die usa werden europäische unternehmen
die geschäfte mit dem iran machen lud
bestrafen
jetzt aber mal halblang donald trump ist
auf der präsident der usa oder von regel
für amerikanischen unternehmen
ausstellen aber zu europäische die kann
er seine regeln länder aufbringen in
denen er nicht gewählt wurde und die
reagiert nun heute werden durch
antworten auf alle diese fragen liefern
aber bevor wir das tun was uns immer
zurück in die geschichte
eine erstes duell immer 2018 musste
sieht die ein chinesischer
telefonhersteller in den usa eine
geldbuße von einer milliarde euro
[Musik]
warum sie importierten mikrochips aus
amerika ausverkauften st
das weisse haus haben sie die auf die
schliche und sagt ihr habt geschäfte mit
denen lösen die uns gemacht jetzt
abgeben entweder jetzt zahlt eine
saftige strafen oder wii verkauft wieder
was zum kran unserem land ein
verkaufsverbot in den usa den reichsten
land der welt ist für einen global
agierendes unternehmen einfach keine
besonders realistische option sieht die
war also bereits alles zu bezahlen um
aus dem us-markt weiterhin leisten
[Musik]
exakt das gleiche gilt auch für viele
andere nicht us-unternehmen aber wie
gesagt europäische firmen treiben seit
2005 zehn geschäfte mit dem iran
und wir sprechen hier nicht von kaufen
sondern von investitionen allein deshalb
hat die eu als chance 1 zu uns da hängt
ja erst einmal auf widerstand
europa hat ausnahmen von trans ihr
ansatz für die luftfahrt und weiterer
branchen im grunde genommen geschrieben
die europäischen staats- und
regierungschefs einen brief an das weiße
haus indem sie die user aufforderten die
wirtschaftlichen interessen europas
respektieren aber wie ihr wisst ist kein
großer fan der europäischen union
ihr könnt euch seine antwort also leicht
vorstellen die europäische union hat
deshalb im august 2008 zehn maßnahmen
etwas wandel floss aktivierung der
verordnung des 171 schrägstrich 60
was moment mal ihr wisst nicht was die
verordnung 22 sich manche kritik ist
keine sorgen dafür bin ich ja da das
ordnung
sie wird was die einen rechtlichen
schutz gilt gegend industrie nehmen wir
zb an der amerikanische
automobilhersteller tesla findet heraus
dass der autohersteller volkswagen
fabrik auf iranischem boden beträgt es
lag könnte die deutsche firma vor
amerikanisches gerichts herren dass sie
zu einer geldstrafe hat in sind nun in
diesem moment würde die europäischen
union eine gleichwertige geldstrafen
gegen tester verhängt aber das ist noch
nicht das ende nicht
[Musik]
ich nehme an volkswagen sagten ich denke
wir werden uns sowieso aus dem iran
zurück ziehen
es gibt hier einfach ist er nun sogar in
diesem fall könnte die europäische union
auf gegen volkswagen eine gelten weil es
technisch gesehen die stationen
washington sozusagen im fluge
vorauseilenden gehorsams akzeptieren
[Musik]
mit anderen worten alle unternehmen die
mit dem iran geschäfte machen befindet
sich in einer patt situation
sie bleiben werden sie von washington
bestraft wenn sie gehen
wir haben es also mit einem verdeckten
politischen duell zu tun
wer ist richtige vorgehen lassen sich
die europäischen unternehmen lieber den
hintern versohlen
[Musik]
wahrscheinlich hat jeder mal irgendwann
irgendwie geld ins ausland angenommen du
liebst die arbeit ist aber so alles an
meine australier
wenn du deine rechnung schreibt es gibt
die nicht die normale firma dann ist an
kundus an sondern stattdessen eine sehr
lange zahl mit einigen buchstaben so was
in der art
diese buchstaben sind der sogenannte es
wichtig dass das system veta
internationalen geld überweisen
verwendet es wird es nicht um ein
netzwerk das alle banken der welt
miteinander verbindet ja herr lang war
der ire anfang dieses netzwerk
ausgeschlossen
selbst wenn nun also mit dem iran
geschäfte machen wollte es ging einfach
nicht wie soll man mit jemandem
geschäfte machen an dem man kein geld
überweisen
natürlich kann man bargeld in einem
aktenkoffer hin und her schicken aber
das ist nicht gerade praktisch
[Musik]
2015 als das abkommen unterzeichnet
wurde kehrte der iran auch sonst ist
systems in diesem moment unter der ära
wieder wirtschaftlich aus die
internationale judentum und jetzt fragt
euch leicht wer kontrolliert dieses
system nun ob die wirbel eine firma
namens swift society for worldwide
interbank financial advisor
internationalen geldtransfers gedacht
gewickelt werden leiden wo es doch dass
diese möglichkeiten geschäfte mit dem
iran zu unterbinden oder dann liegt ihr
total daneben denn hast du das nicht
verstehen das ist eine genossenschaft
das bedeutet alle wichtigen
entscheidungen werden soll der vorstand
getroffen der auslosung 20 vertretern
der wichtigsten der welt zusammen
in diesem vorstand sitzen zwei
amerikaner eine szene citibank und ein
anderer von jay kino
und diese beiden vertreter würden diesen
rhythmus der bezahlen müssen wenn sie
ihre kollegen den legalen funksystem
abzuschneiden
in diesem fall würde der iran wieder vom
internationalen markt isoliert werden
keine geldüberweisung keine geschäfte so
einfach ist das es ist ein so wichtiges
thema das die irgendwelche union beweist
dass du ein alternatives system zur
internationalen geldtransfers so etwas
wie ein modernes system
ist meines wissens der gesellschaft
gegründet werden über die ein teil des
jahres abgewickelt würde das die
handelspartner mit dem amerikanischen
von systemen die idee dahinter ist dass
die europäischen der ware gegen geld
tauschen sondern mit krediten auf andere
waren deshalb nehmen wir zb an
das soll ein spanisches unternehmen mit
öl aus dem iran kaufen statt mit bargeld
zu bezahlen können sie die entsprechende
summe in ausrüstungen für förderanlagen
er sich kann so etwas funktionieren und
dass seine zeit sagen aber nehmen wir
alle ist würde irgendwann mal
funktionieren nehmen wir an dass
unternehmen beginnen dieses
zweckgesellschafts system für den handel
mit dem iran zu nutzen
in unserem beispiel mit apple muss der
dino 16 ist gerade gekauft hat
irgendwann in spanien ankommen
jemand muss ihm mit einem trecker bis in
den hafen von barcelona statt
die meisten öltanker auf dem planeten
segeln unter der flagge der den
reedereien meeres
ja ich weiß den ema hat liegt in europa
aber ratet mal wo das problem liegt kein
hafen der welt würde einen öltanker
einlaufen lassen der nicht versichert
ist
gut ist dass sich heraus dass die
meisten versicherungsgesellschaften zu
öl tanker aus den usa kommen oder dort
viele legale geschäftsinteressen haben
das erklärt dann solche
[Applaus]
[Musik]
jetzt diese märz verlässt den iran da
die gefahr von sanktionen zunimmt
andere länder nicht hier haben bereits
als china steht einfach zu viel auf dem
spiel um einfach so muss eine elster
sorgung aus dem iran zu kappen
es geht um sieben prozent der
chinesischen holen fordert für europa
sieht das sind alles hier ist der iran
nicht wichtig genug um dafür ein
derartiges risiko einzugehen mit anderen
worten falls europa weiterhin rohöl aus
dem iran kaufen möchte müsste es erstens
neue logistik same senden zweitens muss
er sich großunternehmen und drittens
dass die rag jetzt nun baustelle zu
tragen
[Musik]
ok das alles geht natürlich nicht aber
bisher sieht es so aus dass donald trump
dieses hingegen die europäische und das
alles wird weitreichende folgen haben in
einer früheren video haben wir darüber
gesprochen welche auswirkungen die
internationalen märkten haben in den
nächsten wochen werden wir darüber
sprechen was mit dem iranischen regime
geschehen könnte
die große frage ist unterdessen kündigte
sanktionen das iranische maschinen zu
fall bringen um die vielen der ölpreis
steigen
lasst euch instrumental bereichen über
eur theorien das haus und den nächsten
tagen werden wir sehen ob sie mit
unserem übereinstimmen da gehst du auch
nicht dass wir jede woche brannte
regisseur öffentlichen kriegt alles auf
den kopf und das blocken symbol damit
ihr immer eine benachrichtigung bekommt
wenn wir ein update veröffentlicht wenn
ihr die demo fallen hört die uns einen
leid daumen und sie immer was gut bis
zum nächsten
[Musik]
[Applaus]